Pero en realidad se va hacia el cielo
y hacia el universo,
donde ninguno de nosotros hace nada.
Cuando veo este tipo de fotos de la Tierra,
veo una catástrofe ambiental.
No son piedras preciosas,
sino tumores.
Soy astrónoma,
así que no es una sorpresa probablemente para nadie
que siempre me haya gustado el cielo nocturno.
Soy una especie de cliché andante.
Pero cuando era niña en Minnesota,
una de mis actividades favoritas en las noches de verano
era agarrar mi viejo saco de dormir
y llevarlo a un campo detrás de mi casa,
donde iba a pasar horas mirando el cielo nocturno.
Y para ello, tenía que enfrentarme no solo a la oscuridad,
sino también a enjambres de mosquitos,
y eso que mi saco de dormir realmente no olía muy bien.
(Risas)
Pero había una estrella en particular
que iba a buscar, noche tras noche.
Y me gustaba jugar a un juego
donde trataba de centrarme en esa estrella tan intensamente
hasta que todo lo demás desaparecía de mi vista
y solo podía ver la estrella.
Solo podía centrarme en esa estrella
por unos momentos fugaces.
Pero cuando lo hacía,
sentía esa profunda sensación de conexión con el universo.
Y casi era una sensación de vértigo,
como que iba a caer en el espacio.
Y cuando esto sucedía,
—y sé que suena un poco ridículo—
me sentía al mismo tiempo profundamente insignificante
y también, podría decir, extrañamente importante.
Esa estrella que miraba noche tras noche se llama Vega.
Vega es la estrella más brillante de la constelación de Lyra,
que es, y no por coincidencia, el nombre de uno de mis perros.
(Risas)
Pero esta experiencia se está perdiendo.
De mi constelación favorita, Lyra,
esto es lo que se ve desde Manhattan.
Para quienes viven en entornos urbanos y suburbanos,
si salen por la noche y miran hacia arriba,
en vez de quedar impresionados por la majestuosidad del universo,
no ven prácticamente nada.
Estos cielos nocturnos, completamente vacíos,
por supuesto, se deben a toda la luz que producimos en la noche.
Esas mismas luces que se ven desde el espacio
brillan arriba en la atmósfera,
donde rebotan y crean un esmog lumínico indiferenciado.
Y ese fenómeno tiene un nombre.
Se llama "contaminación lumínica".
Como astrónoma,
puedo explicar lo nociva que es la contaminación lumínica
por el brillo de las estrellas que se ven en el cielo.
Y resulta que cuando uno intenta descifrar los secretos del cosmos,
es realmente muy útil poder ver el cosmos.
Y...
(Se ríe)
De verdad.
Y esta luz que tratamos de detectar
viene de millones o mil millones de años luz de distancia,
y por eso la luz es, en general, bastante débil.
Y como astrónoma,
lucho con esto todos los días al hacer mi trabajo,
y tengo que decirles que es un problema muy grande.
Pero el problema es mucho peor
que el hecho de perder cierta capacidad caprichosa de mirar las estrellas.
Por ejemplo,
innumerables especies de plantas y animales se ven afectadas.
Podríamos hablar de las tortugas marinas
o los polinizadores,
o cualquiera de las especies que son tan importantes,
además de bonitas.
Pero quiero hablar
sobre estos caracoles de mar tranquilos y sin pretensiones.
Es posible que los hayan visto
y no les hayan dado demasiada importancia.
Pero son muy interesantes.
En el transcurso de un año,
un caracol de mar rara vez se mueve más de unos 10 metros.
Eso significa que cuando atacan a sus presas
pueden ir a un ritmo acelerado de aproximadamente 1 mm por hora.
Y...
(Risas)
Esto funciona bien,
porque atacan a animales como los percebes.
(Risas)
Estos caracoles de mar viven en la zona intermareal de las costas,
donde son una parte esencial del ecosistema.
No solo son uno de los depredadores invertebrados más dominantes,
sino que otros animales, como cangrejos y aves, los encuentran sabrosos.
Esto deja a estos pobres caracoles en una situación precaria,
porque si se sumergen demasiado profundo, los cangrejos son una amenaza,
pero si salen del agua demasiado, los pájaros se harán un festín.
¿Por qué una astrónoma habla de los caracoles de mar?
Me lo pregunto a mí misma.
Porque su comportamiento se ve afectado por la contaminación lumínica.
Por ejemplo,
si se somete a los caracoles de mar a luz artificial durante la noche,
son dos veces más propensos a permanecer bajo el agua con un depredador.
Esto los pone en un mayor riesgo,
y no es que pueden escapar rápido.
Y por eso...
(Risas)
Y el otro motivo es porque, literalmente, se mueven a paso de caracol.
Si una población es aniquilada,
puede tomar décadas en reponerse.
Y, a su vez, esto afecta al resto de su ecosistema
y a las otras especies, como aves, percebes y cangrejos.
Este es solo un ejemplo pequeño y desalentador
de cómo la contaminación lumínica puede desencadenar un efecto de cascada
sobre todo un ecosistema.
Prácticamente todas las especies estudiadas hasta la fecha
se ven afectadas por la contaminación lumínica,
incluidos los humanos.
Así que vamos a hablar de nosotros.
Probablemente no les sorprenda que la contaminación lumínica
puede afectar la capacidad de dormir bien de noche.
Sin embargo, quizá les sorprenda saber
que la contaminación lumínica está vinculada a la obesidad.
De hecho, un estudio reciente
descubrió que la contaminación lumínica ha contribuido a más del 70 %
de las tasas de obesidad en 80 países.
Más aún, la contaminación lumínica contribuyó tanto al exceso de peso
como a la ingesta de comida chatarra.
Y se pone peor.
Las mujeres que se someten
a cantidades significativas de luz artificial en la noche
tienen un 50 % más de probabilidades de desarrollar cáncer de mama.
Y de hecho, la contaminación lumínica se correlaciona con todo tipo de cáncer.
En experimentos controlados de laboratorio
hay una relación directa entre el aumento de la luz artificial durante la noche
y la tasa de crecimiento de tumores.
Tal vez se pregunten cómo la luz normal
podría afectar las tasas de cáncer.
Quizá todo se reduzca a esa hormona tan importante
llamada "melatonina",
que ha ido evolucionando durante millones de años
para producir el ciclo día-noche, o ritmo circadiano.
Lo que sucede es que cuando la luz impacta en la retina
detrás del ojo, en la noche,
puede interrumpir la producción de melatonina,
y cuando la producción de melatonina se interrumpe,
toda una cadena de otros procesos químicos se ven afectados,
como la producción de estrógenos.
Y cuando este equilibrio químico está fuera de control,
pueden pasar cosas muy malas.
De hecho, son tan malas,
que la Agencia Internacional para la Investigación del Cáncer
ha dicho que la interrupción del ritmo circadiano humano
es un probable factor cancerígeno.
Y, por curiosidad, quiero contarles
que la contaminación lumínica se ha relacionado
con dolores de cabeza, ansiedad, depresión, diabetes,
enfermedades cardiovasculares y la lista continúa.
Pero tal vez no se preocupen por su salud.
Moriremos de todos modos,
así que por qué no morir en una habitación bien iluminada.
(Risas)
El hecho de que se están riendo de la muerte es algo increíble.
Pero quizá se preocupen por el dinero.
El dinero que se gasta en la luz desperdiciada.
Y me refiero solo a la luz que va hacia el universo,
y que no nos beneficia en nada, cuesta USD 3000 millones al año.
Es suficiente dinero para construir 1000 aerogeneradores industriales
o financiar el sistema público escolar de Washington DC más de dos años,
o, mi favorito, porque quiero uno pero no puedo pagarlo...
que es comprarme un Tesla Model X de USD 30 000.
(Risas)
E incluye el beneficio fiscal por ser un auto eléctrico.
Y luego están los costos existenciales.
No tengo ningún dato
sobre cómo el perder el contacto con nuestro lugar en el cosmos
nos impacta.
Pero creo
que esto afecta a nuestra humanidad
más que cualquier otra estadística desalentadora que puedo compartir con Uds.
Y esto empeora con el tiempo.
La cantidad de contaminación lumínica se duplica aproximadamente cada 35 años.
Esto significa que en la próxima década
prácticamente toda la mitad oriental de EE. UU.
será permanentemente más luminosa que el crepúsculo.
Y hay otro problema con la contaminación lumínica.
El problema es mucho peor de lo que captamos con nuestros propios ojos.
Nuestros ojos han evolucionado para detectar solo esta pequeña gama
del espectro completo de la luz.
Toda esa otra luz que no podemos ver,
la luz invisible,
también tiene contaminación.
En gran parte, es por la tecnología moderna,
como los móviles o radares de auto a auto,
o al parecer ahora necesitamos aparatos que puedan hablarse entre sí.
Toda esta moderna tecnología emiten señales fuertes
que pueden opacar completamente
esta luz muy débil que estamos tratando de detectar
del resto del universo fuera de la Tierra,
que, para su información, es la mayor parte del universo.
(Risas)
Y luego están los satélites.
Los satélites son un problema
en las longitudes de onda visibles e invisibles.
Muchas empresas privadas planean poner decenas de miles de satélites
en la órbita terrestre,
donde no solo superarán en número,
literalmente, a las estrellas visibles en el cielo,
sino que al mismo tiempo emitirán luz invisible hacia la Tierra.
Así que para los astrónomos como yo,
que utilizan luz invisible para estudiar el universo,
va a ser como mirar al Sol
tratando de ver una vela de cumpleaños detrás de él.
Muy bien, quiero ser clara:
no hay nada inherentemente malo con estas tecnologías modernas,
con los móviles, los satélites o los radares de auto.
No estoy segura sobre los aparatos de cocina.
(Risas)
Aún no se me ha roto el horno y no compré otro que hable con mi móvil.
Y utilizo luces en la noche como todos los demás.
Pero el asunto es el siguiente:
algunos problemas en el mundo,
como los que hemos oído hoy y seguiremos oyendo,
son abrumadores y parecen insolubles.
La contaminación lumínica visible no es uno de estos problemas.
En realidad, se trata de algo ridículamente simple.
Así que les presento cinco cosas muy sencillas que pueden hacer.
No utilicen luces de más potencia que la necesaria.
No utilicen luces cuando no las necesiten.
Y cuando las usen,
asegúrense de que miren hacia abajo,
para que no estén iluminando el cielo.
Y vamos a hablar de las luces LED.
Si tienen la opción, no compren las azules.
Busquen las de color blanco cálido.
Si compran las que dicen "luz natural" o "luz de día",
es como decir que odio el espacio.
(Risas)
Y finalmente,
Uds. pueden promover esto.
Incluso en su comunidad local, averigüen si hay un código de iluminación
y si se lo puede hacer más amigable con el cielo nocturno.
Incluso podrían abogar a nivel federal
para pedir amablemente a las autoridades federales,
y quizá haya aquí algún representante,
que por favor no subasten al mejor postor
nuestra visión del universo invisible para contaminarlo a voluntad,
que es en realidad lo que sucede.
Ahora bien, como buena profesora,
tengo tareas para Uds.
Si nunca han visto un cielo nocturno verdaderamente oscuro,
quiero que salgan y lo vivan por sí mismos.
Porque si no lo hacen,
no saben lo que se pierden,
no saben lo que la humanidad está perdiendo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)